so one reason i i appreciate you there
are a number of reasons i appreciate you
sarah and admire you
but one is that you spent probably
uh the equivalent of years um
spending spending time in different
communities around america trying to
unpack people's experiences
and then you responded uh trying to
unify
through kindness and understanding which
is really such the opposite of like the
customary approach
that that people seem to have
particularly in like the the kind of
cycles of social media and the rest of
it
i just saw it as such an uplifting quest
on your part
and the fact that you could actually
do that in like a you know major
platform and
the way that you did i thought was very
very
singular like i thought to myself was
like is there anyone else who could
uh pull this off at this level and i
could not think of a soul except for you
yang thank you i do yeah i mean it was
definitely
i wanted to challenge myself to say like
i really want to
i try to do comedy that has
heart that is still hard comedy like
still
you know and um and
i also think we're we're all connected
and i i don't think we're as different
as we feel
because we're being separated by
misinformation
i also feel like it it isn't
progress like if i consider myself
progressive
progress is to change so like i'm wrong
a lot and i love
changing i don't feel i it's exciting to
me you know when i go oh nope i've got
to say
you know like re remember the new words
the new pronouns the new whatever you
know like
i even see my boyfriend going like yeah
i met with this girl
woman today you know and it's those
little things
just seeing that that there's an
awareness in his head clicking off
you know from just what is so ingrained
in us as i find that stuff
exciting you know but there is that
thing online and it so often comes from
the left of
just wanting to draw a line in the sand
and point to you
as wrong and get to point to mia's right
we get so excited to be
right and point to someone who's wrong
and and i
i know i participated in as well but i
try to remember
to if do we want people to be changed or
do we just want to be able to point to
them as wrong in ourselves as right you
know
like it's just like well remember well
four years ago this person said this but
you know neil brennan has the best joke
about this
his analogy is like somebody going up to
lebron james and going
we have a picture of you when you're 14
and you're only
five two i'm like well but i grew
yeah but is this true is this your
picture are you five two you know
lebron was never five two blasphemy
you took the harder approach i think
that that's part of why i appreciated
admired it so much
you tried to build bridges of
understanding people who had
you know a different um world view or a
different political sense
and i think we really needed that
uh we still need it you know like that
there is
still such like a uh
divide uh and it is getting worse not
better for a variety of reasons
and i see you as one of like the few
people that tried to tackle it in a
meaningful
personal way that actually invested
you know years of your life in it it's
something that
i feel like i can relate to because like
i undertook a similar mission
in you know in a political realm um
and no to the extent that like i made a
contribution i'm really proud
um but i feel like you've been doing the
same kind of work for years
and when i look at folks who are trying
to do it
like there aren't that many like it's
not like a
a huge legion uh of folks who actually
are
trying to understand people who have
completely differing
politics or world views yeah and it
takes so little to connect i mean you
went from town to town and you talk to
people and you connect
i always say like when friends go i
can't even talk to this part of my
family they're you know these
trump cue whatever crazy conspiracy
and i go do they watch walking dead you
know i don't know like it
you know there's always something and
once you connect
they're more open we're more rope well
we're all more
open and we were primed for
change you know but it to just be like
i do notice on the right like the thing
that
they're most closed about is like
feeling judged
you know have you read uh jonathan
heights work i feel like you would love
it uh if you haven't
no um he wrote a book called the
righteous mind
that talks about the way that uh
conservatives and liberals have uh
different
moral palettes and i think you would
love it where he talks about how there
are
um six universal values
uh let's see if i can get this right
it's a
caring fairness
liberty loyalty
authority and sanctity and progressives
naturally
skew towards cheering in fairness
and conservatives naturally skew towards
loyalty authority and sanctity
and then we construct liberty in
different ways either personally
or societally but look at loyalty and
authority they're so connected to
fear oh yeah conservativism
corresponds to things like threat
sensitivity and disgust reflex
where like if you uh if you generally
are like you know
turned off by disgusting scenes or like
uh different types of uh even food um
you're more likely to be conservative
really yeah and uh
appetite for novelty corresponds to
liberalism
where if you just like new stuff you're
more likely
to be politically liberal i i read a
study that
when you're in a state of fear you no
matter who you are
you make more conservative choices and
that's why
you know um the right uses fear you know
the
caravans coming or whatever they need to
create to
make their followers malleable instead
of
be curious question things be interested
fight that human fear against the
unknown
you know and it is true that works on
liberals too where we give more
conservative responses after you scare
us
it's a you know it's a pretty universal
impulse we also apparently
get a bit more conservative as we age
yeah and we have to try to fight that
though
because you get set in your ways and set
in your ways means conservative
yeah it's um i mean you know i i looked
at myself it's like i you know i feel
like
that hasn't really happened to me as yet
but uh who knows man you know we're
still young
it happens to me in that like all i want
to do at night is like
watch a columbo and go to sleep yeah
i've become like old in that way but
when i hear like comics go oh we have to
learn all these new words or we can i
can't use this word or i have to be
sensitive to this topic
i can't say anything you know i go well
that's what old people
are like you don't even like you can't
embrace new that you can't think of new
words you can't think of something else
to say than
you know like i've used this a lot this
example a lot but i used to
defend saying gay or that too gay
because i go i'm from the boston area
it's i have gay friends it's not
you know what and then one day i just
heard myself and i was like
well you know what i'm the guy who goes
what i say colored i have colored
friends you know like
i'm him and you're like i don't want to
be that person yeah
surely i have other words i i i'm like
my job is words i can think of other
things in two seconds and then
yeah it's so odd that instinct to want
to stay the same
jonathan hates research really
opened my mind in a different way and
when i traveled the country like i had
an experience that
did verify a lot of what you just said
which is like if you actually
talk about the things that people want
for themselves their families
uh the things they enjoy like we have
more in common than not
it's just that right now there are
massive
forces that actually unfortunately make
more money
uh putting us against each other that's
what it is
clicks yeah a lot of it's clicks
um some of it's cable news and cable
news ratings
yeah if you have a 24-hour news channel
that's not news
they have to fill content and they need
to keep you to you know
uh through the commercial to come on the
other side it's that's entertainment
you know i mean you know what i mean
like yeah obviously fox news but
you know msnbc anything that's 24 hours
is gonna be
is gonna have um bait
[Music]
you